foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsey
personality George Campbell joined by
the incandescent Jade warshaw this hour
and we are so excited to take your calls
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five this is a show about you your
life your money your struggles your
success and we want to celebrate with
you we want to cheer you on we want to
encourage you we want to give you some
hope and uh Jade I've had about 17 000
people DM me with like in-depth
Financial questions and I go call the
Ramsay show I wish I could sit here all
day long and ignore my family at night
and answer all these but it's so much
easier to talk to you guys that's right
please call in we love the DMS but this
is the right format get through it I'm
so glad you brought
me too but I had a post go viral on Tick
Tock last week of course you did George
over 10 million views it was a clip from
this show I took a call from a 19 year
old who wanted to make a million dollars
by the time he was 26. okay and so now
all these 19 year olds are messaging me
going hey I want to build wealth too how
much should I have in crypto and I'm
like okay call the show we'll walk you
through this so yeah triple eight eight
two five five two two five I'm Yoda that
makes you Obi-Wan I don't know I don't
know
what's that guy that I don't know what
that was but I think what you were
trying to get at was Chewbacca
Wookies Wookies is that right I was
waiting for one of the Nerds in the
booth to help me out but they left us
all hanging so we'll just get to the
I've never seen the movies so I feel
like I'm really winning at life right
now it's time all right we're gonna
start off with Ethan and Austin what's
up Ethan how's it going
hey guys appreciate you taking my call
sure how can we help
yeah
um my question is regarding whether I
should uh sell my van that I currently
live in kind of an RV
um for a down payment on a home oh okay
so you're done with the RV life for now
you want to settle down
well not necessarily I'm curious whether
I should sell it or go into an apartment
with my buddy and then either you know
kind of rent out the van
um or to just live in it during the
winters so the options are I could sell
it and rent somewhere or I could sell it
use that as a down payment and buy a
house
kind of yeah so sell it use it as a down
payment on a home or rent an apartment
in Boulder and keep Auto and then keep
it yeah and then the other six months of
the year during the winter uh travel
around in it and then try to sell at
least the apartment do you need to sell
it to make a down payment or do you
already have additional cash set aside
um I have additional cash but not enough
to avoid PMI so what percentage are you
at right now by the way 20 avoids PMI
for anybody listening
yeah I have about 10 grand and I was
looking to go in on the home with a
buddy so I would need 30 all in what do
you mean with a buddy
uh best friend from high school we're
thinking about either going in on an
apartment together or at the home oh boy
but it would be under one person's name
right like you're not
uh yeah probably and then we we'd figure
out not probably no this this is where
it gets dicey because then five years
from now one of you moves out and goes
cool give me my half yeah what happens
then one of you needs to own this and
not only one of you needs to own it but
whoever's the owner needs to be able to
cover the rent on their own and the
other person renting it's just gravy
does that make sense so there's no
weirdness
okay that makes sense so I would not
jump into a home unless you can afford
the mortgage on your own on a 15-year
fixed where the payments no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay
in that case
yeah I would rent until you can do that
yeah I'm just too risky
you make 58
uh 68 gross so take homes probably about
50 to 55.
okay so we're talking close to 4 500
five grand a month and so you don't want
that mortgage to be more than about 1200
bucks and that means on a 15 year you're
probably looking at saving up for a
longer period of time
even after selling the RV
okay which here's the thing
um you're nothing's on fire right you've
got this RV you enjoy that lifestyle
enough for it to continue to be a
lifestyle even after you were to buy a
home so you've got time to really keep
saving up and really keep weighing your
options here and I you know we said it
before but I also want to clarify even
on the down payment don't split the down
payment if you're buying this house let
it be your home
um and just to you know take your time
maybe get your income up if you want to
do this a little bit faster and then to
the point where you know okay I'm ready
to sell the RV or maybe you decide by
then you don't want to sell the RV so
there's no rush is my point how old are
you
uh 23 just graduated college awesome and
how much debt do you have if any
uh none came out no debt great and that
10 grand is that including your
emergency fund do you have a separate
emergency fund
that is that's including emergency fund
with uh being in the van it's only about
1200 a month for living expenses all in
okay so let's say for your new life down
the road this 10 grand is your emergency
fund so we're starting from scratch now
to save up for the down payment what
could you get for the RV
um low estimate 35 to 40 Grand
man I that thing's going down in value I
might sell it while you can drop it like
it's hot while the Market's still hot
yep
and uh and then rent with a buddy which
is a lot safer bet while you save up
could you still do that
I could yeah Boulder rents uh 1200
minimum there oh because you'd be moving
yes
um
well you might need to have three
roommates and get a bigger place that's
right make it a party
but uh either way you're 23 I know it
feels like man I gotta get my money into
an asset I want to be a real estate
owner but doing it the slow way in the
right way is going to give you so much
more peace yeah man making this whole
thing messy with the buddy of yours
who's who's I'm sure a great guy but
it's going to turn that friendship into
a business transaction and it's going to
destroy it eventually and I like what
George said about get however many
roommates you need at 23 you can do that
kind of stuff you're unattached you
don't have kids there there that is such
an opportunity that I think a lot of
people don't see when they're in it but
then when you come on the other side
like me you got two kids and a husband
to try to live cheaply like that is like
unheard of so really take advantage of
that so that you can buy your home when
the time comes in the best possible
position I love it does that help you
Ethan give you some options it does yeah
awesome well best of luck to you man
that's a cool goal to have I wish I was
like the RV guy I feel like I I need
like a normal shower and a normal bed
yeah I'm kind of jealous of the like I'm
23 I live in the RV and I just travel if
I promote have like the glamping
experience where it's like you could
park the camper where you want but
there's got to be like a just like a
Hilton nearby where you can take a
decent shot like there's got to be
somewhere in between there it is but the
RV life is great for a season but I
found many people call in and they do it
for a while and they want to they want a
semblance of normalcy and they've kind
of they did it they got it out of the
system and they're ready and the problem
is RVs go down in value they do well
he's his has got a pretty value and I
love what you told them to do get out
while the getting's good before it drops
even more six months from now that thing
could be worth 32 Grand yeah six months
later 30 grand and so I'd rather put
that towards saving up the down payment
and getting into that home thanks for
the call man more of those coming up at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsay show
thank you
foreign
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
well Jade you came up with this idea I
cannot take credit but you wanted to do
the first tell-all on the Ramsey Show
Jade and George tell all
right explain what's going on here I
feel like this is a moment of
vulnerability like I'm really brene
Browning right now and I'm not prepared
for it well you know I think when it
comes to our budgets we're always
wondering how we're pacing with the pack
right we want to know is what we spend
on groceries the same as what everybody
else spends what we spend on
subscriptions is it normal is it in the
middle are we going crazy and so we
thought it would be cool to talk to you
guys about one of the areas that we're
always telling people to cut down cut
back subscriptions so we're gonna share
on air our actual subscriptions that we
pay for the action the workshop family
and the camel family who's gonna
10 million dollar question should I be
brave you want to just do all of yours
and I'll do all of mine is that how this
works well okay let's just go pound for
pound because then I won't feel as good
all right this is monthly like I'm
paying monthly for this Spotify okay
that's legit what's yours mine is 14.22
cents a month uh so I'm on a family
account
because you can have up to like five
accounts like my brothers on there my
mom and dad and my wife okay that's
great so that really brings the cost
down to just a few bucks a month I think
it's like four or five bucks a month I
need to try that check it out all right
XM radio 26 dollars and eight cents oh
and you're free in your car yeah
seriously yeah I don't do that I got the
Tesla you know so I'm just well
so I'm usually just playing you know
Spotify like your own playlist yeah
yeah okay that's yeah that's fair it is
you want to know what we'll come back to
that later because I have thoughts on
that okay okay ring subscription like
ring doorbell 3.99. oh you're right I
have Nest I have that too I think it's
similar I think it's like five bucks a
month for nest okay so while we're on
that also I have nest and that is you
got ring and Nest yeah I thought I put
it on here um it's not a lot it's it's
oh there it is Google Nest six dollars a
month okay that's the one I have I got
like five cameras all hooked up to that
well then I also have ADT oh my goodness
Jade this is for home security I try
it's it's Fort Knox up at the war shop
all right all right
um Hulu 22.17 I think okay that's fair I
don't think we have Hulu anymore we cut
it good for you
um there's just too many at some point I
had to decide so then at that in that
case you're about to judge me hard
because here we go I'm just gonna name
these Hulu 2217 Netflix 2161
ouch peacock 999 Disney plus 19.99 yeah
wow I have laid
I'm proud of you it bear here on yeah no
caviar we're not mad at subscriptions
we're mad when you're not paying
attention you're broke and you're
wondering where all your money's going
yeah I mean that's 125 a month if I were
to cut those my life would go on I'd
probably be a more productive human
being I'd be more exposed to the world
because I wouldn't have all my security
but life would go on and I'd have a 125
dollars to throw at debt that's legit
and your family enjoys all of these
hopefully now let's talk do you have
yearly subscriptions like ones that you
only pay once you pay yearly and Save A
Buck I'm I do that yeah so that's me so
a lot of these are yearly uh shipped
instacart I have both of those
now I guess Costco and Sam's Club count
whoa that's a subscription kind of would
you call that a subscription membership
oh it has an annual due oh that's a good
point okay um I have Costco I don't know
what it costs I'll be honest I don't it
always stands up 20 bucks a year for
their own membership that feels right
but oftentimes I'm so Frugal that I'll
find deals like there's like a Groupon
for Sam's Club where it's like 15 and
they give you a 15 gift card and it's a
wash and so that's that's why we have
both what's your most like out there
subscription uh I would say dog food
is that a subscription well I have it on
auto so every month okay they ship us
the very expensive dog food for our our
broken dogs or French Bulldogs who just
have so many allergies I just don't know
that I would call that a subscription
because think about it like on Amazon
Prime let's say like your paper towels
you use it all the time you can do that
thing where it's yeah auto-ship okay
we're not counting that I don't think
that's look you guys can weigh in if
you're watching on YouTube weigh in on
the comments I wouldn't call that my
most crazy yearly subscription I have my
husband I got my husband something
called scentbird
cologne colognes yeah that's cool it's
once a year it's like a I think it's 144
a year okay then Beachbody
uh
oh they've gotten really expensive I had
Peloton for a while and I was like this
is 50 60 bucks a month and I don't ride
the thing so I just sold the Peloton and
canceled the subscription I I might have
needed to buy your Peloton so I could
have gotten rid of this speech body for
179 a year Well gym memberships alone
can get very pricey some of these bougie
gyms so you gotta pick your poison there
the other ones I have are nerdier uh you
know Apple iCloud storage oh I got
Google drive storage now because they
kept emailing me with threats of like
we're going to delete all your emails
from 2008 if you don't give us a dollar
I was like all right isn't that like 99
Cents though it's like two bucks yeah
okay and the Apple iCloud I've got like
the two terabyte because I'm an apple
nerd I got too much stuff it's like two
terabytes worth it that's the world we
live in so did you do any math on this
like I calculated it for the year for
the year it's about
1962 a year that's fair I think mine
adds up to about a thousand a year yeah
so don't I guess the lesson the moral of
the story here is just because something
seems small that stuff adds up to big
numbers and this you know it kind of
goes both ways if you're trying to make
changes in your budget you're trying to
pay off debt don't think oh it's just
six dollars it doesn't count like you
add that stuff up that's two thousand
dollars a year if you got thirty
thousand dollars of student loans
wouldn't it be nicer to have twenty
eight thousand dollars of student loans
I mean that's really the way you got to
look at it and a lot of the time we
forgot what we even subscribed to and a
good way to do this on your iPhone is go
to settings click on your name I'm gonna
do it with you and then here's the crazy
part you go into subscriptions and it
will show you why you're broke
oh it gives you a little list of active
subscriptions and it'll tell you there's
another one I didn't write down
what is it it's called prompt smart
that's right and it renews May 4th wow
well it just did there you go if you
have an Android device this is really
easy you take your device throw it away
and buy an iPhone there you go I'm just
kidding the Android users can't defend
themselves they're all hating me I'm
just but George I've never had more
respect for you than I do in this moment
why
because you just laid down the law you
laid down the nitty-gritty right there
it's just fun it's fun to play it's
because you got your ankles out that's
true and oh there's one I forgot about
with my wife Whitney doesn't do this
right now but seasonally she'll
subscribe to something called newly
n-u-u-l-y hashtag not sponsored but it's
like a clothing subscription so you can
rent like six pieces of clothing for the
month and then send it back and get six
new pieces of clothing for the month and
then send it back that sounds like a
great Frugal hack so like for the winter
time you want a coat for the summer time
you want to dress you can just kind of
use them seasonally and not have it take
up space in your closet so this is kind
of like Rent the Runway but for an
entire wardrobe yes wow and what's it
called again newly n-u-l-y all right you
heard it first here guys again none of
the we have no affiliation with any of
these companies we're just we want to be
specific yeah but people then go oh
there's spawn no it's not yeah not
advertisers this is not an endorsement
no the point is your own caution that's
right the point is to show hey like
we're not up here trying to like look
down on anybody we're doing the same
thing every day we're trying to get our
budget right we're probably have areas
where we could cut back on if we wanted
to you know like everybody's doing this
everybody's doing their best nobody is
that's right sometimes we do a little
judgment here let's be honest about that
but when you're in baby step two and
you're going well I just can't I don't
have an extra dollar to spend and I look
at your budget and I see you way
overspent on food the way you're going
out to eat three times a week you're
getting you know snacks at the gas
station you've got all these
subscriptions that you don't need it
might be time to cut some of the
luxuries that we love for a season yeah
so that we can have freedom and peace so
we cut subscriptions that's a big one
most people need to cut out going out to
eat or even food or grocery budget what
do you think the third big category
would be a weird one that people don't
think about is insurance people are
overpaying for insurance and I go hey go
shop with our friends at Xander and see
and they go oh my gosh you just saved me
300 a month between all of my different
my auto my homeowners bundling it all I
had this old Ensure insurance plan I
never checked it out so that's a big one
that is pretty easy and you can save a
few hundred bucks a month wow so do that
coverage checkup tool that we have and
you can kind of look through that yes
love it this was helpful stuff George
all right we try to be helpful in the
show even if it saves someone out there
a buck it it was worth our time that's
right to do it so a buck is enough
listen we're not mad at subscriptions
we're mad at subscriptions that are
costing you your financial future little
by little those little ankle biters and
it all adds up don't tell me it doesn't
you can have this subscribe descriptions
don't let the subscriptions have you
that's what it is this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour the phone lines are open
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money James is up next in
Cincinnati James welcome to the show
hey thank you very much for having me
absolutely what's going on
um so the biggest thing is
um I'm starting my own business this
year by the end of the year I believe
and I want to find a best way to get
retirement and so I'm not working until
I'm 70 years old like my grandpa in the
same type of field cool what kind of
business
uh it's a masonry construction business
love it and is this going to be solo for
now
uh yes I believe almost they kind of
more from over the years listening to
him and other people around us I think
I'm gonna say uh super small I kind of
want to be more like independent maybe
have a a labor with me to help me out
every once in a while but for the most
part just stay kind of single yeah cool
and you're going hey I don't work for an
employer I'm not going to have a
traditional retirement account what are
some ways I can go you know beyond a
Roth IRA go beyond that to invest
yes exactly that's the biggest thing
right now because I got money in the
bank kind of sitting and I'm about to
start up with my own business and
everything so I really don't know what
to do right now I'm kind of stuck I I'm
trying to figure that out now well once
you get started with the business I like
what George said for now you know just
that Roth IRA while you're making money
at your current job or moving forward
but once you get into your business and
you find that you've got you know that
margin laying around than what my
husband there's a couple options a lot
of people like the the sep fund or you
might look into an individual 401K it
really depends on how much money you
have that's disposable that you're able
to put away
um which is cool we ended up with an
individual 401K because you can
contribute it from both the employer
side and the employee side and the
limits are pretty high I think at some I
think you might want to double check
this but I think they're like 58 000
like you can really throw some money in
there
um depending on the type of business you
have and if it's low overhead and you've
just got money
um whereas with the sep you're only
going to be contributing to it from the
employer side
um so you've got some options there I
love that you're thinking ahead because
so many people when they set out with
just their
um self-employed business they kind of
forgot they forget about that part or
it's kind of like you know their head
down they're just trying to grow their
business and they kind of forget like
especially if they're the only one in it
I need to be putting away for retirement
yeah that's big and the one that came to
mind for me was the solo 401K that Jade
mentioned that's a that can be a great
option for a lot of solopreneurs out
there and allow them to invest even more
than a traditional employee so you have
a lot of options out there I would still
connect with a financial advisor who can
walk you through all of your options and
get health insurance this is a big one
for self-employed people they go uh
health insurance is expensive because I
don't have it subsidized through my
employer I'm just gonna skip it do not
do that because you'll be the next guy
calling in with 100 Grand of medical
bills because you got hurt in your
construction business and didn't have
health insurance so look into the solo
one 401K solo 401k and HSA which is a
health savings account which actually is
kind of a really cool way to invest as
well it's a really cool retirement tool
when done right that's right so James
you got a lot of options man I'm excited
for you I love it yeah yeah definitely
me and my wife we have a 10 month old
baby
um she's a nurse herself so that's where
I kind of get right now I'm actually
considered on my parents Insurance
because until I'm 26 I don't have to get
off so I'm under my dad's right now he
has a union teaching job so I'm so under
him so my wife is just paying for her
and the baby right now
um so yeah I definitely trying to plan
ahead for sure because my grandpa he is
78 this year and he's still out there
working and he never got a chance to do
these things because he really never
thought about it he told me the other
day but if I knew back in time I
probably never had my own business to me
it kind of scared me a little bit I was
kind of like well shoot should I be
doing this but I think with the passion
I have for it and the understanding with
um being as young as I am the
understanding of how to plan out and I'm
pretty decent with my money
um I have money saving the bank but I
just really I was went to the bank the
other day and deposited and check and
the guy was like well yeah this money's
sitting there what do you want to do
with it oh boy
do not take advice from the the bank
teller please someone just sent me a
fortune cookie that said a banker will
sell you an umbrella while the sun is
still shining there it is right there
definitely so but it got you thinking
yeah like so it got me thinking the
other day I was like man I need to do
something because me and my wife have
some money saved up we have it set to
the side and it's just sitting there and
I just don't really know what to do so I
think I'm only a full fledged with this
business but I really want to just of
course be successful have money in the
bank to where like if I need to get
something done or if I need to do
something for my child human's always
there and but still like to enjoy life
so like I'm just trying to find that
happy medium like what to do well I want
to give you the book entree leadership
as you start your journey and just
remember move at the speed of cash as
you build this thing don't go into debt
either on the personal side or on the
business side and I love look you're
setting yourself up for Success you're
asking all the right questions you're
digging in deep
um I think that's what's really going to
differentiate you from your grandfather
right you're learning more you're
expanding your knowledge and I'm proud
of you very good yeah you run this
business debt free you put money away
for retirement you have retained
earnings for or whatever future expenses
or emergency things that come up with
the business and you're going to be just
fine my man I'm proud of you at this
young age to have that kind of mindset
crushing it thanks for the call let's go
out to San Jose Nick joins us there
what's up Nick
hey how's it going thanks for having me
sure how can we help
yeah so um I live in California and we
had a lot of wild weather this year and
I actually had a landslide at my house
um yeah pretty pretty heartbreaking
um my house didn't go into the river but
a lot of our our property did and
there's just a lot of repair work to get
done and I'm looking at a really Hefty
Bill I'm wondering your thoughts on
paying for that
um as you know it's not something that
insurance covers land movement like that
so and looking at selling it by myself
what what are what type of numbers are
we looking at here
um of engineering and my permits and
construction like around 250
000 so bear everything goodness yeah
okay what's the house worth
about 7 50 roughly and that's if you get
these repairs done
yeah yeah I don't know what it is today
in the current state goodness gracious
how much money do you guys have
like in savings yeah
yeah um like 120 in savings and then we
have a brokerage account with like 90.
oh good what type of Investments are in
the brokerage account
is it single stocks is it
no it's a it's a it's money managed by a
financial advisor I'm not sure exactly
what all the different funds are in
there what's your household income
uh about 160. okay and do you have any
debt
know that just the mortgage but we have
two other mortgages that are investment
properties oh okay so that's what I'm
wondering really about do we sell a
house possibly and pay for this even
though those are money makers every
month and you know long-term Investments
or do I take out another loan
for you know nine percent or more you
know well we're going to take debt off
the table as an option because this is
this is an emergency and when you use
debt for an emergency it turns into an
absolute crisis right because now you
owe you know with even more zeros on the
end so I I love that you've got cash
sitting around
um I would liquidate the cash down to
your three to six months of emergencies
and I put that towards it and then
you've got this brokerage account that's
aside from any other retirement you
could dip into that
um and then you know you could consider
selling a house if you still need more
money
um
the key here is Cash is King right
yeah
so here here's the sad news is all the
stuff that you've worked so hard for
stacking up this cash the taxable
brokerage account the investment
property we now need that to keep our
life going and you'll get back there I
have no doubt uh the fact that you got
here tells me you can do it again but I
would liquidate that brokerage account
make sure to account for taxes on the
gains on that I would liquidate that
cash you have on hand down to a
three-month emergency fund and you might
need to sell an investment property if
you can't come up with a cash fast
enough for the repairs and can find out
about any coverage for landslides if
there's anything out there and if not
let's think about how we can plan
hopefully this never happens again but
how we can plan more for the future but
between your cash that you have in the
taxable brokerage your savings and your
future cash flow income you might be
able to start this repair work and then
six months from now have another 50
Grand saved to finish this out so it's
not going to be fun man I hate that
you're going through this that hurts and
I'd also look into do we need to move is
it worth doing these repairs could this
happen again how do we protect ourselves
from the future because getting another
hit of 250 you know six months from now
a year from now that could tank you guys
and I don't want that for you
[Music]
foreign
if you listen to the show you know that
paying off debt is smart and saving and
investing is smart but there is one key
to winning with money that people
Overlook all the time and that is
protecting your finances from
emergencies and that's exactly where
insurance comes into play now there's 10
kinds of insurance coverage you might
need based on what your life looks like
today and to make it easy on you our
team has built a tool called the
coverage checkup to show you exactly
which types you need to add drop or
adjust we'll even rank your coverage
list by importance we'll email it to you
and connect you with a Ramsey trusted
insurance provider so you can get your
plan in place fast seriously this could
be the most important five minutes you
spend today go to ramseysolutions.com
checkup and take that checkup coverage
tool and it's ramsaysolutions.com
checkup do not let an emergency sneak up
on you protect your family that's right
and I have to interject because we were
hosting earlier this week and a guy
called in didn't have the right coverage
on his wife
got in a wreck and he owed big time
remember that yeah I mean not having the
right insurance will cost you huge and
even if you have the right type you
might be overpaying that's right and so
I like to shop mine every year just to
say am I still getting a good rate yeah
some of our rates went down this year
which was great love it all right let's
get to the phones John is in Wichita up
next John welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call sure um
I'm looking for some direction I'm about
eighty thousand dollars in debt and I
just don't know which way to go
of what type of debt is it
um
20 000 in student loans 26 000 in a car
10 000 in personal loans
um 20 000 on a Snap-on tool truck 3000
on Matco tool truck
yeah
so
I want to get into this a little bit
further but let's just get the specifics
out of the way what are you earning
right now
um right now I'm earning with two jobs
about 67 a year
67 a year two jobs what are those jobs
um I work for my father a W-2 employee
as a mechanic and then at nights I'm
going to cook at Old Chicago
okay mechanic can you explain those two
trucks a little bit more to me
what's that the two trucks the 20 000
and the twenty thousand
no uh one's a student loan and then
um the 20 000 is a tool truck so I have
tools that I use for work
got it okay not not an actual vehicle
no got it okay Okay so
you're making 67 what is the car worth
the car is worth 14. oh so you're way
underwater on this thing did you roll
negative equity into that
rank out of a bad relationship and got
rid of the vehicle and yeah okay how
much money do you have liquid
um right now I've got a little over a
thousand two jokes okay so that's your
baby step one your starter emergency
fund so our next plan of attack there's
no there's no easy shortcut life hack
here other than work your tail off get
the income up get all expenses down and
throw the margin at that next smallest
debt
okay which in this case would be uh that
small tool truck the three thousand
dollars
right okay but here's here's where I
want to dig in
and you're never borrowing money again
right
correct I don't have any credit card
that I got rid of that I paid that off
I've been slowly paying stuff off how
old are you
I'm 35 35. this is this is a tough
lesson to learn I mean you're gonna have
to kick it you're gonna I mean I I can
hear it in your voice you're like dang
it like I how did I get this much debt
but it's that reflection of looking back
and going man what caused me to do this
what caused me to to to get this ten
thousand dollar loan what caused me to
pay twenty thousand dollars for a tool
truck what caused me to do this so that
you never do it again
right right so John here's a fun way to
reverse engineer this and I'd use this
when I was getting out of debt on
average if you follow the Ramsay plan it
takes people 18 to 24 months to get out
of debt and so if you went all right I
have 80k in debt I want to pay it off in
two years that's 40 000 a year that's 3
300 a month what do I need to do in
order to throw 3 300 a month at debt
that helps me have a very specific goal
because right now I'm guessing you don't
have much to throw at the end of the
month after your bills are paid
how much do you have you can throw at
the debt
um probably a thousand great so now we
know the Gap we need to go make another
two thousand dollars somehow somewhere
maybe it's getting a better side gig
maybe it's getting a third gig maybe
it's doing overtime with your mechanic
gig whatever that looks like for you in
order to to shrink that Gap and let me
let me drill one bit further
um if you in 10 years
your wise are you a mechanic and a cook
or what does that look like for you
um hopefully you're just a mechanic and
you know moving up in the business okay
so that's the that's the dream job right
there is the mechanic
right okay are you able to do that work
outside of your full-time hours
yes okay that to me is your best bet
because your hourly rate on being a
mechanic versus being a cook I assume is
much higher
correct okay it's about 22.
awesome and could you even raise that
could you say I'm gonna do side work at
35 bucks an hour for people
yes definitely and uh do you live in a
neighborhood
correct I mean there's probably a
Facebook group in there I'd post and say
Hey listen I'm doing I'm changing out
breaks I'm doing simple stuff I can do
in your driveway I charge 35 bucks an
hour
here's a reference and I bet you'd get a
bunch of work this weekend just by
posting that
okay yeah so get creative and get
excited because right now man it feels
hopeless doesn't it you're just like oh
my gosh how did I get here the breakup
the negative equity the debt is stacking
I don't want to do the side job but man
when you have that windshield and you're
looking out going two years from now
John's gonna be debt free he's gonna be
in a different situation he's gonna work
a second job because he wants to not
because he has to
yeah definitely that's right there is
there is hope at the end of this that is
the good news and we're going to give to
you one year of Financial Peace
University as well as one year of every
dollar premium to help you along this
journey and I want you to call back when
you're debt free my friend we're
cheering you on thanks for the call
that's a tough one George I know
Survivor said it there's no easy way out
but John's not scared of work and that
tells me There's Hope yeah and you he's
got it he's got to just use that as fuel
for the fire because you could hear it
in his voice he was like defeated man
like Ugh
I hate this yep all right let's take one
more from Andrew in Atlanta Andrew
welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's going on with you
well
um I have been in a sales role base plus
commission uh almost two years and I
have only I've been selling every single
month consistently that I've been with
the company but I've only got one
commission check and I'm supposed to get
it every 30 days so
in my mind I've already made up what I
want to do I
kind of want to just hear somebody else
say it and make sure I'm not making an
impulsive decision or for whatever
reason a bad decision well have you
spoken to your leader about this
uh several times what do they say
uh so I try whenever I bring it up to
the manager who pays it out
um one of two things happens it either
gets pushed off or it gets
um
you know I'm working on it I get the
answers like yeah I'm working on it
there's nothing to work on though you
close the deals right the money's in
their accounts
how big is this organization
uh total of 13 people do you think
there's a lack of Integrity here
no and that's the catch it well not a
catch but that's the I don't think
anything illegal is going on my family I
got this job from from a family friend
basically they're they're we've known
them for years we you know years could
go by and I find out this person's been
arrested for embezzlement I don't know
to the best of my knowledge there's
nothing Shady or illegal going on it
might just be having trouble paying
their bills and balancing their books
and not have not being managing the
money well not necessarily doing
anything illegal either way I want to
get paid on time I yeah put food on the
table and cover my bowls and therefore I
have to go find a job that can do that I
mean you can fight for your commissions
that you earned I think that's that's
wise to do but I don't know if you'll
get them at this point yeah it's time to
roll out man I'm so sorry what do you
sell yeah
uh so industrial grade painters okay I
would start looking today for something
in a similar role that can pay you on
time while you're owed and what you're
worth and get a get a new job before you
quit your previous jobs
pay them what they're owed it's not that
hard you can do this check out entree
leadership if you want to learn more
about how to run a business the right
way how to do leadership the right way
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books
foreign
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsay
personality George Campbell joined by my
fellow Ramsay personality the exuberant
Jade warshaw joins me this hour and we
are more than enthused to take your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five Andrew
kicks us off in Dallas Texas Andrew
welcome to the show
hey guys so my question is that I've got
the only debt I've got is 190k on a
mortgage First Mortgage
I've got about two hundred thousand
dollars in a CD my mortgage rate is
three three quarters my fee is over five
percent
so I'm wondering you know what would you
do would you still pay off the mortgage
or hang on to the CD sometimes it's
outpacing the you know the mortgage rate
um yeah this is a common question in
today's world where people locked in
these super low mortgage interest rates
and now savings interest rates are Sky
High and they're going why would I even
pay down this mortgage I'm making money
hand over fist in the savings account
and I understand it mathematically I
understand it there's one piece of the
equation is risk of course of not having
a mortgage means less risk 100 of the
homes that get foreclosed on have a
mortgage unless they don't pay property
taxes that's pretty rare so one side of
this is going if I didn't have a
mortgage payment what could I do and
start dreaming about that vision for
your life and the other side of the coin
is the actual math of going well what's
what are you paying right now in
interest every month on that mortgage
have you actually looked at the
amortization schedule
but we're probably talking you know
north of 600 bucks
just on interest alone for sure yeah and
so when you start to look at the numbers
on you know five percent on 200 000
that's 10K a year you know you can start
to do the math and go all right divided
by 12 that's I'm making 800 bucks by
keeping this 200 000. now most people
don't have 200 000 sitting in a CD you
are very weird in a good way to have
saved up this amount of money was this a
windfall did you work to save this up
um a little bit of both so you know I
got a pretty decent bonus uh about a
year ago at the job so okay and what's
your income
150 kilometer
so what would be the harm play it out
where you you cash out the CD and you
pay off the house and you still have
some other savings I imagine that are
liquid
I do I mean not a lot that more or less
kind of takes me to your emergency phone
which
yeah I mean I've definitely got you know
I'll probably get another 30 grand of it
okay and then what's your mortgage
payment every month
um it's like 800 bucks
oh nice yeah I pay you know I pay a lot
more uh just trying to pay it off
quicker yeah
well we tell you what we would do if we
were in your shoes and what we would do
is pay off the house if we had the money
sitting there I definitely would I mean
I I tend to look at statistics on this
too
um we know 67 of millionaires have paid
four homes that's what they do they pay
off their residence and they understand
that that's a major part of their wealth
building plan
yeah and you'll still have of course
property taxes and insurance but if you
take that chunk out of principal and
interest that you're throwing towards
the house and go what could I do with
that the extra 500 bucks I'd have every
month well you're probably going to
invest that because that's the kind of
person you are and so you're going to
see 200 Grand again but right now it
feels like I have 200 Grand liquid when
really you owe 200 Grand on the other
side and so I would rather be free I
sleep better not owing anyone anything
especially with all the fear right now
in the economy and it's just a simpler
life when you don't have a payment in
the world so I'm cheering you on if if
you pay that house off today man that
would be fun go down to the bank and do
a wire transfer and call it a day oh
what a great never have to think about
mortgages again love it thanks for the
call great conversation let's go to
Isaiah in Phoenix up next Isaiah what's
going on
yeah I have uh twelve thousand dollars
in savings and I'm trying to determine
if I should assist my fiance in paying
off credit card debt no or no
or save it first no
you you hit Jay you activated it
why do you want to pay off your fiance's
debt
um
down to her parents but she you know we
want to qualify together
um possibly
what do you mean qualify
uh qualifying a house together I will
say she has eighteen thousand dollars in
debt where I actually have zero dollars
in debt besides ten thousand dollars in
student loans here's the thing I love
and plus the 10K okay hold on you're not
gonna pay off your student loans but
you're gonna go pay off her debt
look he I I admire that you're he's got
a good heart here he's got a great
intention but it's very chivalrous yeah
it's this is the wrong plan
in your mind because you're not married
yet right this is your fiance you've got
good intentions you want to be debt free
you're putting her first like I I think
I see how the wheels are turning in your
brain but it's a bad plan because you're
not yet married yet and so we don't want
to combine money we don't want to pay
off debt I'm not trying to put any bad
you know Juju on you to say that you're
not getting married but just be patient
and let that run its course and in the
meantime each of you work on paying off
your own debt you've got 10K that you
need to pay off she's got 18K she needs
to be working to pay off when's the
wedding
uh wedding probably in about a year or
so oh yeah you guys can knock that out
what are you earning right now
uh myself I'm learning about 70 to 85k a
year she's a nursing student she's not
really making any income not yet that
has to be paid when will she finish
school
in September oh nice so she'll be
working by the time you're married
yes making a great income so here's a
goal I would have if if I was sitting
there in your shoes fiance's I would go
hey how cool would it be to start off
our marriage debt free with money in the
bank and cash flow the wedding and
honeymoon
mm-hmm that would be my goal over the
next 12 months but right now it's her
debt my debt my money her money my
savings her savings
so that would be you have 12 cane
savings I'm paying off your 10K today
what's stopping you from doing that
uh
uh for a house I don't know if I should
Isaiah you're not ready for a house man
let's let's walk him through it let's
walk him through Isaiah because I I feel
him he's he's he's got good intentions
they're just misdirected okay the house
is the biggest purchase you're ever
going to make all right it's the most
important purchase we want to make sure
it's done right the best way to buy a
house is after you've paid off all of
your debt and when you've got three to
six months of savings set aside and
you're able to put down a nice size down
payment so that you're making it to
where when you buy the house that
payment is no more than 25 of your
take-home pay so that every day when you
turn the key it feels great walking into
your house there's no bird in there you
can you know lay in the backyard in a
hammock and just be at peace right we
want to create that right now you've
both got debt she's not working there's
a right way to do this and you're not
going to go in to buy a house together
until you've got that money saved until
you're both married right yes this is
the way we're working this plan I would
enjoy newlywed life first and just rent
not have to worry about home ownership
and then down the line when we're ready
we'll do that and we want to give you a
little pre-marital gift and that is
Financial Peace University I want you
and your fiance to go through it I think
it'll light a fire under you both get
rid of your debts separately so that
when we come together it is sweet holy
matrimony and Financial Peace on top of
that so hang on the line Skyler's gonna
pick up we will gift you one of your
Financial Peace University
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw this
hour and we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five well Jay this has been the The Talk
of the Town all in the news yes guess
who's back
back again student loan that's right oh
man so we can pretty much say that by
the end of August we're going to be back
on it it's time to pay the piper right
when student loans come back online and
you know I think that this has got
people feeling some type of way right
because we've gone three years I mean
people have like almost graduated
college in the time that student loans
have been paused they don't even know
life of a student loan payment they
don't even know about it and then
there's the folks who you know they've
not had this reprieve and they've
created a whole new life and they bought
a house and they have a whole new budget
400 student loan payment for a 400 car
payment and now they're going wait wait
I got another payment coming oh I can't
afford that yeah and I'll be the problem
it's a problem but I'm glad that it's
going away because I just have to throw
this number out there in case nobody's
heard do you understand George that this
student loan pause has cost the U.S
taxpayers
5 billion
billion dollars per month that's a
thousand Millions but five of those
every month since this pause has
happened
the taxpayers are paying that that's
insane so I had to hit that because that
because I don't think a lot of people
have dug in to understand like there's
no such thing as a free lunch whenever
some things quote unquote free it's not
actually free taxpayers are paying it
people who don't have student loans
people who never went to college single
moms teachers everybody's been paying
for this so they're coming back online
and I feel for the people who are like
dang it uh I was paying my student loans
before and for some reason it seemed
like they never went down why is that so
we want to give you guys some practical
information this hour and this is the
hour where you need to take out a pen
and paper if you have the ability if
you're listening in your car or whatever
save this and come back to it later
because this is so important we're going
to teach you and break down your student
loan payments so you actually understand
what's happening every month and so that
you understand this is how you gotta
attack your student loan to ultimately
pay it off okay so let's just take an
average number George let's just say
you've got thirty five thousand dollars
that's about what I had in a student
loan all right let's say your interest
rate's about 400 annual interest rate
four percent
that's what this says oh I think you
said 400 I was like I'm gonna throw up
that's like payday lender level no no no
four four percent that's kind of you
know what we're looking at so we want to
understand what percentage of our
payment is going to interest right so
here's what you do it's three easy steps
we're gonna figure out how much we're
paying each day in interest so you take
and you calculate your daily income or
I'm sorry your daily interest rate
here's what we do we take the four
percent and we multiply it by 365 days
right so .04 times 365. yep and we're
going to get a number it's going to be
like 0.000 you know 10959 so whatever
your number is fill in that blank take
your interest rate
0.04 or 0.08 whatever your interest is
and we're dividing it by 365 days
because there's 365 days in the year
that's step one step two you're going to
take your full loan balance and you're
going to multiply it by that previous
number so we're going to take 35 000
because that's how much we owe and now
we're multiplying it by that daily rate
right and we see that we're paying three
dollars and 83 cents per day in interest
doesn't sound like a lot but it adds up
it adds up now we need to find how much
we're paying per month so we take that
3.83 there's 30 days in the month so we
multiply it by 30 days and that gives us
a hundred and fifteen dollars so in this
case that person is paying a hundred and
fifteen dollars per month in interest
now you go hey that doesn't seem too bad
here's the problem on its standard
10-year payback plan right for this
person their payments probably about 354
dollars so we know okay out of 354
dollars that 115
is interest in the rest of it 239
dollars goes to the principal here's
where we get into
trouble everybody wants a lower payment
George everybody says oh I need the
income based payment or I want the the
lower payment I don't want to pay so
much on my student loans so what happens
if this person calls up their lender and
says hey I I need to I need to lower
this payment give me the lowest payment
possible that person might get on a
payment plan maybe a 20-year plan where
that payment goes down to 113 and you
feel like I'm winning I'm paying less
but here's the problem if your payment's
113 you're not even covering the
interest the interest didn't change the
interest does not change and so if
that's how your balance is going up so
many people on payment plans they extend
the plan and they wonder why isn't my
student loan moving as a matter of fact
it feels like it's getting bigger so
here's the rule of thumb larger payments
are better all right I kind of came up
with this thing when when these student
loans come back tell yourself lower as
in lower payment equals larger and
longer lower
equals larger as in your your balance
gets bigger
because of the interest and longer which
means you're going to be paying it for
much longer you do not want a lower
payments a 15-year mortgage over the
30-year your payment's higher that's
getting paid off in half the time with
less than half the interest that's right
so so don't control for these traps
don't fall for it get out your pen and
paper and work through this and figure
out okay because when you see it's like
when you have a home you look at that
amortization schedule and you go oh I
get it like I see why I need to pay this
thing off and it's the same thing do
this math do this little bit of hard
work let me tell you something right now
I'm confessing I hate math I love money
don't love math all right but I make
myself do it because I want to see it
and it's so important for you guys to do
this because with these student loans
they're sneaky and and and they drain
our energy right nobody wants to think
about it we want to bury our head in the
sand right peacock status is it peacocks
um ostrich yeah there we go I don't know
what peacocks do I gotta Google Now
feathers but look when it comes to this
stuff I say it all the time ignorance is
not Bliss it's broke all right that'll
preach it's broke you gotta look at this
stuff you can do it the next step then
is just getting on your budget right
George and if you have had your head in
the sand who knows what has happened in
three years many people had their loans
sold to a different lender yeah uh your
payments may have changed you may have
gotten married you've changed an address
you've got to get this stuff dialed in
so contact your lender get all that
figured out figure out exactly what your
payment is who it's with what the
interest rate is and then start to plan
for that in your budget and that might
mean oh we gotta stop eating now we got
to cut some subscriptions we gotta pay
off the car so that we have room to pay
for the student loans we can attack that
there's going to be some life change
happening this summer oh yeah it's the
summer blockbuster that nobody wanted
student loans are coming back but you we
can frame our mindset around this George
we can either look at this and go oh man
oh miss talks or you can look at it and
go oh I get to get debt free
I I get to I get to pay off my debt so I
can have a better future I get to pay
off my debt so I can have peace I get to
pay off my debt so I can build wealth I
get to pay off my debt so I can send my
kids to college I get to pay off debt so
I can go to the restaurants that I want
to go to without feeling guilty every
time like right yes that's what this is
It's reframing that dichotomy and you're
and I think we need to get riled up and
to do that go listen to The Borrowed
future podcast series that I did and you
can go watch the documentary on YouTube
for free under the same name borrowed
future and I interviewed some folks who
have the saddest stories people who took
out 15K and then owed 60. yeah people
who took out 80 and didn't realize they
were going to be paying 120. that's
right that's the kind of stuff that gets
you angry enough to pay this off and the
interest is coming back the payments are
coming back it's not going to get
forgiven by Uncle Joe listen it's just
not going to happen even if the 10K
happens that's a drop in the bucket for
most of your student loans look and at
this rate that 10K would be back in
interest lickety-split let's be honest
about that yes and I just I I have to
say this I I to say this
in our country there is
people's people have got it twisted they
have confused truth with popular opinion
and that's problem and when it comes to
the popular opinion that oh the
government should pay for this I got
duped the government should step in and
pay my student loans matter of fact they
should pay everybody student loans
matter of fact you know that continuous
but here's the truth the truth is you
signed up for it
you signed up for it and when you signed
your name and don't get me wrong we're
18 we didn't have a clue and these
student loan companies are predatory but
it's not all your fault but it is your
responsibility we're not saying it's
your fault but it is your responsibility
do what's right do what's right make the
right Next Step which is pay off these
loans because uh the government doesn't
have a great track record of solving all
of your life's problems it's the person
in the mirror and that hurts at first
until you go oh I'm in control the
person I can control that guy that's
right and so we have full faith that you
can do this because I've done it Jade
has done it many people on this debt
free stage have done it and you're next
so what are you waiting for you're gonna
keep watching the headlines waiting for
your life to change are you just gonna
get up off the couch and go change it
you got next you got to decide America
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw this
hour this is your show America so call
us up with your questions about life and
money at triple eight eight two five
five two two five well a lot of you are
planning to move sometime soon tis the
season and that's awesome I'm excited
for you but let's be real in most places
around the country you'll still be
facing sky-high home prices and interest
rates well they're not exactly returning
to those record lows that we we love to
see
but that doesn't make home ownership
impossible if you want to buy or sell
you've got to make sure you're
financially ready and you've got to have
a trusted and experienced real estate
agent to walk you through this not a
family friend who just got their license
last month not someone who does Real
Estate as a part-time hobby on the
weekends you need to be working with a
pro who's a true expert in your local
market and they know how to negotiate a
strong deal how to Market this thing to
get the best price to get the best deal
and you can find High Caliber Ramsay
trusted agents just like that through
our endorsed local providers program and
since we vet Agents from around the
country you'll have the best support
whether you're moving from Florida to
Alaska or buying your first home
somewhere in between just go to
ramseysolutions.com agent to find a
Ramsay trusted real estate agent today
that's ramseysolutions.com agent
Randall joins us up next in Houston
Randall what's up
you've taken my call sure what's going
on
uh so I just got married uh middle of
February and then soon after my wife and
I found out that we're pregnant and so
just wanted to see uh what the best
steps are to set uh my family up as well
as as our future child's up for
financial success awesome so you want
you want to set up the family and the
child and what does financial success
mean to you define that for us
retiring early and
um not always having the baggage of
um of weighing every decision based on
the money factor so just less brain
calories burned because of money
yes sir love it and how old are you two
uh so I'm 26 my wife is 24.
and what's your household income
um it's about 85 right now my wife is in
between jobs but she starts a new one at
the end of July and it'll be about
another 50. okay awesome very good what
kind of debt do you guys have
wow good job and you got money in the
bank
uh let's see we've got about 10 or 12
Grand cash and
um right around 100 000 depending on the
day with Investments oh is that just in
a taxable brokerage or is that
retirement
uh so some of it's in retirement about I
think 84 ish of it is in an ETF
um about 15 of it's in a Roth IRA and
about three grand is in a 401K with my
employer okay so the ETF is outside of
retirement
correct cool okay so what are your
future goals because we can set we can
walk you through the baby steps which is
invest 15 uh if you have that fully
funded emergency fund which I I think
you're close is the 12K cash close to
three to six months of expenses
it's probably around three or four okay
so we're still building that so I would
up that before baby gets here once the
baby's here we can set up a 529 plan and
get college going and put a few hundred
bucks a month away there while you guys
are putting 15 of that awesome income
into retirement accounts and then what
would be your next goal is it to be
homeowners you guys have a house
absolutely no we don't need rent right
now okay
um but possibly uh homeowners in the
next couple years I'm just trying to see
what the options are and what it looks
like I know the housing market is
absolutely nuts right now oh yeah well I
would liquidate those non-retirement
funds and use that as a down payment you
could definitely do that that would be a
great plan especially right now with
even high yield savings accounts
interest rates you might want to
liquidate now and just sock it away over
there at four or five percent and not
worry about what the stock market does
based on what someone tweeted or what
the government who knows what and I
going in I you know I feel like we kind
of don't we talk about all the time that
we want you to get you know a 15-year
fixed rate mortgage where the payment's
no more than 25 of your take-home pay
all in we talk about that a lot but I
think sometimes if you're a first-time
home buyer I know I experienced this
there are those fees up front that are
big percentages of money that we don't
really think about and I want to kind of
go over that a little bit I I came up
with this little acronym that I think
helps I say make sure you have a stacked
deck DEC because you've got your down
payment which is substantial and if
you're making an offer a lot of times
you need earnest money which is the E
and then your closing cost which is the
C so that's a lot of money just add a k
for to make me feel good just call it
kitchenware all right there we go on a
budget for kitchenware and there you go
but that's what I'm talking about is
making sure not only the down payment
that is a big thing but sometimes we
forget those other costs that are really
big and you want to have the camera just
having a couch to sit in yeah so you
guys are in a good spot you've got like
George said you've got money you can
liquidate and you can still continue to
save towards a as well but kind of
thinking through that and going what
does this mean you know of course your
down payment anywhere between
you know 10 to 20 percent five percent
I've heard some people say
um your earnest money sometimes that's
one to three percent of the purchase
cost and then your closing cost could be
anywhere between five to seven percent
so that's a lot of money to think about
and you've already got a great head
start and Randall we're we're cheering
you on because you're asking yourself
how to set yourself up financially
you're already doing the work by
remaining debt free and having money in
the bank saying cash positive increasing
your net worth those are the kinds of
moves that allow you to burn less brain
calories with every financial decision
how does that sit with you was that a
lot
it does yeah the one thing that I'm I'm
hesitant on is I know that when I'm high
interest uh savings accounts they can
make uh whatever percentages three four
five percent but is that something to be
worried about with inflation being
higher than that
no I would not even if it was two
percent I still think it's a wise move
if you get a home purchase coming up in
the next year to keep it liquid and not
put it into the market because we just
don't know and what I would hate is a
year from now you had 84 a year ago and
you go to buy that house and now that
account is down to 70. that's right
because of some dip in the market and it
hurts emotionally and it hurts
financially because now you're set back
with your down payment savings goal
yeah we've done extensive studies on
that
um the difference between leaving if you
were to put money and you know the
market to save the difference between
keeping it in five years or more or less
than five years that the chances of you
having gains on it goes down
dramatically if it's like one year three
years that's why we say don't put your
money in the market for savings unless
you're going to keep it in their long
term five years or more so in your case
that's not really what we're looking at
so that high yield savings account is
perfect the purpose is not to outpace
inflation at that point it's just to
save for your down payment and I'm sure
the Houston area housing is pretty
expensive and so I would sit down with
your with your wife and go hey what kind
of house is reasonable for us right now
we may not be able to afford that dream
home that we really it may have to be a
town home for now and that's okay we're
gonna get a 300 000 town home instead of
a six hundred thousand dollar single
family home or it's going to be 20
minutes further than we wanted it to be
so there's going to be some compromises
and Home Ownership is never perfect and
so you've got to kind of know that going
into it to not be emotionally Jarred and
scarred
I understood okay thank you yeah
congrats on the upcoming baby that's
exciting can you imagine well I guess it
happens a lot you get married in like
lesson you're like we're pregnant
when you don't have debt and you have
twelve thousand dollars in the bank like
Randall and you're not stressed about
how are we gonna afford this baby yeah
it becomes a line item in the budget and
so we always say in the baby steps
there's no baby step that is have a baby
right you can have a baby in any baby
step will it be more financially
peaceful to have that baby once you're
debt free with an emergency fund sure a
thousand percent do people have babies
all the time while they're in debt and
they survive yes but still make it a
priority to become debt free get the
emergency fund and Jade more than ever I
think with today's economy and the news
everyone is going I feel like I can't
keep up with inflation I'll never be a
million I'll never be able to and so
they start doing these Hail Mary
shortcuts buzzer beater Financial moves
that end up hurting them way more than
it helps them yeah that's right you know
you just you kind of have to just stay
the course on this and keep going strong
keep saving and if you you don't like
the rate that you're saving you might
have to increase your income in a way so
that you can say save more but the key
is don't make rash choices don't make
Speedy choices take your time
and do it right yeah but you won't
regret it the less exciting the
financial plan sounds the more it's
probably the right one that's right if
it sounds too good to be true and it
sounds like if I just did this one thing
this guy said if a guy said then maybe
it's not the right unless it's George
unless they're sitting at this desk and
that guy or gal has a good head on their
shoulders because we're not trying to
steer you to get rich quick we're trying
to steer you to get rich slow and have
peace in your life which is about the
opposite the way the world is going
right now we are far far away from peace
and we're all aiming towards it it's
what we really really want deep down
we're here for you America this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour opened phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five hey if you're
a new listener to this show and you want
to dive deeper into the Ramsey Baby
Steps all the stuff we talk about on the
show the lingo you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button and we will help you
figure out the next best step for your
financial Journey based on where you're
at today that's ramseysolutions.com
click on the get started button our
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
spring is here and neighborly can help
keep your home and yard in Tip-Top shape
with the Grounds Guys mosquito Joe
Precision garage doors and Mr Handyman
so spend time enjoying your home not
working on it go to neighborly.com to
find service pros in your area alright
today's question comes from Mark in
Wisconsin he says a year ago I bought a
loaded 2022 Santa Fe with 18 miles for
about 38 100 dollars after a year of
payments at 391 dollars I'm starting to
regret my decision I owe sixteen
thousand four hundred dollars on the
loan and CarMax is offering me thirty
one thousand six hundred dollars for the
car I put fifteen thousand down when I
purchased it and I could pay off the
loan by selling it and be left with
about fifteen thousand all right can I
look at this as a learning lesson uh
kind of like a lease and sell and go
back to my motto
of it's just a car
that's his motto
um
yeah I I these questions sometimes I'm
like I want more context I want to know
what your income is what percentage of
your income is this of course I hate car
loans I want to know what other debt
that you have
um but at the end of the day if you
don't like the car you regret having the
car and you can get out which is rare
when you can get out and still have 15
channels this is a wonderful situation
as far as reversing the stupid tax yeah
I'm like go get
get your 15K because they put 15K down
and they're saying they're going to get
15K out of it yeah so yeah he's coming
away it's a wash you basically got to
drive the car for a year and have a good
time and now you're done with it oh he's
oh so you're saying it's a watch it
sounded like he was saying that he would
be left with 15K did I read it wrong
which is what they put down so 15 plus
their year of payments is what they paid
into it so they lost a little bit of
money but not too bad it could have been
way worse you know a whole lot worse
with cars being underwater today yeah so
so can you go back to his motto I say
yeah it's just a car sell it sell it get
out of it get you something with that
you're paying cash for that you don't
have a payment in the world
to this day Jade the newest car I've
driven that our family owns is a 2013.
me too I'm still behind the times me too
George to all these people out here
driving 20 22 loaded cars I'm like must
be nice we're out here paying cash look
being reasonable and and it's an omen
because we both said 2013 and do you
want to know what I paid for our
2013.15k that's what's up that's what's
up right you're gonna get a nice 2013
vehicle with your 15K you sure are and I
love your motto it's just a car and you
want to know it you're going to feel so
good because you're gonna secretly know
inside when you just walk through the
parking lot of Costco or when you take a
walk through your neighborhood and you
see all the vehicles You're Gonna Go 717
dollars a month 862 dollars a month I
wish
Jay just what if if you had a car
payment you had to stamp it onto your
windshield
do you think we drive differently yeah
yes George I'm scared people would flex
and be like twelve hundred dollars yeah
there would be the people who were so
just like mortified to put it on there
and then there'd be the people the Bro
dudes who'd be so the truck Bros they've
got the lifted they've got the under LED
kit going on spent spent twelve twelve
hundred dollars I'm like bro what do you
use that truck bed oh you go to Lowe's
once a quarter to get some mulch okay oh
I'm glad you had to buy a 60 000 truck
to do that goodness gracious yeah cars
just have never I people go with George
you're not a car guy I'm like what is a
car guy I think
we all enjoy a nice car I wanna I own a
nice car yeah but the thing is I want to
own a car to where the next car I get is
the nicest car I've driven the problem
is buying new cars is that anything else
feels like a downgrade but when you're
in debt you're doing it the wrong way
that car is going down in value while
you continue to pay interest yeah it's
one of the stupidest forms of debt you
can get into that's right he's doing
right
it's just a car who cares what other
people think and every time you turn
that ignition you feel that regret it's
just not worth it so I'd sell it thanks
for the question all right let's go to
the phones Lindsay is in Portland Maine
Lindsay welcome to the show
hi so
um so glad it's you and Jade today can
you hear me okay you can we're glad it's
Lindsay
I'm sorry we're glad it's Lindsay on the
line how can we help yay so I've been
following you guys for a while and we
completed um the Financial Peace
University and we have Gone Bananas for
the past uh eight months we've paid over
um a hundred thousand dollars off on
debt already come on somebody
yeah and we just uh sold our home it was
a really big deal but we ended up
um profiting three hundred and sixty
thousand dollars
that's awesome no our big question
though is we have
350 in student loan debt oh wow
okay we're right so we're kind of in
this position of breaking even if you
will
um to then be able to have this cash to
pay off are you guys like doctors or
lawyers or something
yeah so my husband has a master's in
finance and I'm a nurse practitioner
okay where are you living now since
you've sold the home
so everyone thinks we're crazy we
um currently are waiting to get into a
rental that's available July 1st okay
awesome what's your household income
we currently make between the two of us
to 250 000. heck yeah okay and the only
debt is the student loan debt or is
there more
no that's now that's currently it we I
have 250 and my husband has 80. because
all federal we pay so so our initiative
we um we cleaned out our savings and we
paid off the private at the end of last
year and then um we've just been saving
saving saving and paying paying off um
our debt we sold we we were those people
we had um I now granted our interests on
our cars was like one percent but we did
have a thousand dollars a month in car
payments on a big truck and an Audi and
so we sold both of those and um I'm so
proud of you guys 2012. Equinox
awesome so so Lindsay um no kids right
we have two kids so that's part of our
initiative our big thing is we were
trying to hustle my husband worked
overnight stocking shelves at a grocery
store for the past six months to bring
in an extra two grand and
um I have three jobs and we're just
tired we're tired of just working these
long hours yeah we're willing to do it
and we know that our plan would have
been accomplished within three to five
years to pay off the 350 but we just
felt like selling the house was just a
better move to be able to kind of
actually to get out of Sallie Mae's jail
free card and now when this rental comes
available July 1st and the whole
family's living in there is this a
situation let's let's hypothetical let's
pretend you use this home sale pay off
all the debt right and you're starting
at Ground Zero you're in a rental it's
gonna I mean you've got a great income
but you're still gonna have to save up
for down payments and closing costs and
all you know get your three to six
months all of that stuff
mapping out the timeline of this right
and maybe we find out hey it's going to
take us a year it's going to take us two
years well that rental
um take you there like is this the type
of situation where it's like no better
than a a hotel room right with the
family and it's like oh we're on top of
each other we can't stand it or can you
get this
it's a family friend who bought it for
two or three years down the road for her
elderly mother it's a three bed two bath
with a yard come on a desirable
neighborhood touchdown five minutes from
my work yeah that's incredible so
and we were dry I was driving probably
on average an hour and a half to two
hours a day with where we were we
previously blessings all around no
no-brainer for me this is a no-brainer
for me George I'm paying off the suit
loans you're gonna have an emergency
fund Left Right Lindsay we will we'll
have a full six month emergency fund
left with our current every dollar
budget and our
um profit this is not a coincidence this
is like a God thing and I'm I'm gonna
use that and your next goal is to save
up a house down payment and making 250
you can throw 100 150k into a savings
account and be back in the house a few
years from now come on touchdown love it
winds all around here Jane that puts
this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books my thanks to my co-host Jade
warshaw all the folks in the booth and
you America thank you for listening
we'll be back before you know it
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell joined by Jay warshaw this hour
and we're taking your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you've got a burning question on your
mind you don't know who to go to you
heard something from your brother-in-law
you're not sure if it's true you saw a
tick tock you want some confirmation or
validation we're here to help you take
the right Next Step for your life and
your money Refugio is going to kick us
off in Albuquerque Refugio what's going
on
uh yes good afternoon I'm calling
because I had a question I uh I called
Merrill Lynch because I work for Walmart
and so I have 401k and I'd gone to a
live search uh it's it's this Christian
uh uh business kind of a church event
nonetheless
um to get to the point uh I thought I
would be able with the uncertainty of
times be able to take out some of my
401k and go ahead and pay taxes which
might not be the brightness idea at
least I could start investing on my own
uh with the tools that I learned from
Life search well nonetheless when I went
to call uh Merrill Lynch they told me
that I could not get any of my money out
on this I were to leave my job quit my
job and I'm like well I don't want to
quit my job and so my question is and
it's kind of like scary I never stop
that you could put money in and not get
it out
have y'all heard of that or were they
cautioning you of
what could happen if you were to remove
this before retirement age was it more
like hey you can't access this money
it's your retirement money
or was it does that make sense because
they may have just been adamant because
they didn't want you to
remove your retirement money or was it
like no matter what you can't take this
much like I'd love to have more context
into that because we would tell you hey
don't know about your 401k right we
would tell you not to pull it out
yes so no matter they were like
um they were like the only way you can
take out your money or any part of it is
if you have a hardship
uh and they they kind of told me either
you're going back to school
um uh you have medical expenses those
would be things that would avoid the
that and those would be things that
would avoid the fees and penalties
so I have a hunch I don't know that I'm
right I would I would say call them back
but I have a hunch that they were saying
you can't pull out your money without
penalty and without tax unless it's this
which is great advice by the way
you know I did ask him that question I
go can I can I get uh even because I
told him how much I was going to get I
said well can I get half of it and I I'm
aware of paying taxes and I'm aware that
is going to be a 10 penalty she goes
well the way it's set up with your
company you can't uh you won't be able
to get it until you're 59 and a half or
you can actually prove that you have a
hardship okay I would go to your HR
department to just get the fine print on
this and figure out what's going on but
the good news is you're not going to do
that and here's why I Refugio I don't
want to be the bearer of bad news I'm
scared you're about to fall for some
kind of scam yeah my red flags were
going up and up and up when you started
talking about this event you went to and
they said to cash out the 401K because
the times are the end times are near and
you got to give us your money and we'll
invest it the right way
does that not sound a little kooky
what it does what what they were saying
is they have this program which we're
going to go back and it's in Oklahoma
City where you would learn how to day
trade or stuff no dearly Lord no big big
big no in big bright red flashing events
they're telling you to day trade Jesus
would be flipping the tables up in that
Temple okay look Refugio you called this
show and we dude we love you we want the
best for you do not do this keep your
401k your 401k it's Trucking along it's
earning you know intro it's compounding
keep that you don't need to get into day
trading that is not and guess what those
stocks are a part of the same stock
market that your 401k is with so if
they're truly talking about some hedge
against inflation the end times this
ain't it and I'm scared they're about to
take all your money leave you broke and
now you have no money in your 401k and
you lost your money elsewhere
yeah so I don't know what this is I
could be wrong about this but if there
was the word day trade in there it's a
scam at an event and they're telling you
to cash your stuff out and put it in
this to be safe man I would run fast and
I would run hard and I'm mad at them let
me just tell you I'm mad that somebody
told you that that is the worst advice
ever all right so you got two folks
we're we are gangster for you do not do
it and I'm mad at the folks who told you
to do it that's so messed up Refugio
please avoid 401K withdrawals avoid 401K
loans avoid day trading and avoid any
event where they tell you the end times
are coming liquidate your assets and
give it to us we'll know what to do with
it
goodness gracious that scared me oh I'm
so glad he called us oh my heart is
palpitating right now okay let's see if
we can get a quick one in here from
Emily in Atlanta Emily what's going on
hey how are y'all good we're up against
the clock what's your question today
um
a thousand dollars in my savings
um just from working I did not go to
college and uh
um I worked for my parents currently and
I'm just like wondering where is the
best place to start investing okay do
you have any debt
I do not no sir um my parents I was very
blessed growing up and they've taken
care of everything for me up till today
or up till now that's awesome okay so
this 20 grand is part of that an
emergency fund
um I don't have any bills honestly um I
still live at home my parents take care
of everything for me um your insurance
um at the business do you have a car
yes sir um I have a car and they paid
for that as well is it paid for or
they're paying the payment
no it's paid for great okay I'd still
set aside 10K just to be safe because
car repairs deductibles insurance I want
you to have some cushion there but with
the other you know 9 10K you have you
could fully fund a Roth IRA if you have
earned income
you're working yeah yeah I do
I do yes I work for parents um
um right outside of Atlanta
um and probably in about five to eight
years
um I'll be purchasing it from them
eventually and so my income will
significantly grow like go up that's
awesome what's your income today
um around 40 000. awesome you're
crushing it what's your plan for moving
out are you moving out soon or
the market in my area
um like like I said we're right outside
of Atlanta so it's not the best thing
right now
um
and I don't want to rent at all that's
like not on the table and so I don't
know I thought about looking whenever
everyone you know says things come down
but I don't even know things are going
to come down I wouldn't go time the
market Emily but I would start saving up
a down payment now that you have the
emergency fund invest 15 of your income
into retirement accounts like that Roth
IRA into good growth stock mutual funds
and get connected with a smart investor
Pro these are investing professionals
that we trust to invest the right way
and they'll walk you through how to set
the Roth IRA of how to look at the
Investments the right way what to choose
and they will guide you through that but
man you're going to be a baby steps
millionaire no time way to go
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's back either one
their wash and guarantee and
and she's always free see whyblinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings go to blinds.com
now and save 45 off selected products
visit blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
want to chat if you want to talk shop
about money and life if you got a
question we are here for you this hour
Daniel is up next in Atlanta Daniel
welcome to the show
hello
um uh how do you vote um so Ma I've got
a I'm kind of in a world of of trouble
here um I have about uh 265 000 worth of
debt and uh I just got laid off for my
job as part of the reduction in force um
yeah so and um and no worries I'm
pounding the pavement trying to look for
another one um but uh
yeah that's uh is this a big shock or
has this kind of been on the verge for a
while
oh no it was I didn't nobody knew about
it it was like I mean in fact
in fact we had our CEO tell us um you
know uh the week before that uh
you know and a meeting and the whole
company attended uh he's like you know
you see all these companies like Amazon
uh Google
um laying off people but um we're not
going to do that and then the next week
that happened I mean about 200 other
people
wow wow what were you making
uh about 220 uh plus uh bonus would be
20 of my um base and then I got rsas uh
every wow year as well you were crushing
it so how much money do you have in the
bank right now
um all total uh let me see
um let me find it where I have it on
here uh forty five thousand three
hundred nine dollars and eight cents
okay and do you have anything you could
liquidate to get you by and start paying
off the stat like those stocks are they
vested
well no they they once I get terminated
they take them away all the ones they
weren't vested
so what kind of debt is this are we
talking cars can you break down that
debt so we can see where we can help you
out here
yeah
um it's it's a mix of credit cards a lot
of credit
and two car loans and
um one of them is uh so one of them is a
BMW and I'm upside down in that one
um uh basically uh I would have to pay
uh thirty thousand dollars to get the
actual value of the car to you know to
get rid of the car like you owe it's
worth 30 and you owe 60.
yeah like that thanks
happen
bad decisions did you roll negative
equity in
I'm sorry did he roll negative negative
equity from another loan or what yeah
so why do you have the two cars do you
have more than one person in the
household
no um actually the other one is a a car
that um I had a loan on it was a
different kind of loan this is where you
um you it was the kind of like a lot of
credit and I got the title up front and
then
um I this is another dumb mistake I
didn't realize that I had done that with
that car and when I got another car I
traded that car in but I still owed on
the car so you don't even have the
vehicle but you still have the damage
yes goodness gracious okay all right
this is this is where it gets real
because at this point
yeah well here's my question Daniel
truthfully where is this amazing income
been going
uh
uh bad decisions trying to say that give
me are you do you have a spending
addiction is there another kind of
addiction I'm trying to figure out the
root of this so we can help restaurants
women
um you know during my 30s and everything
like that and it's built up until now
and so I I can tell you that my
lifestyle is not the same
um and it hasn't been for the past I'd
say four years and I'd actually started
the debt snowball
um you know I'd say probably
um maybe eight months ago
um started it um you know um and again
didn't see this coming but I guess my my
bad decisions from my 30s um you know in
my 40s now
um it uh crawled up to me and hey so I
want everybody listening to learn from
this right now this is the prime example
of how you cannot out earn stupid like
stupid decisions those decisions they
catch up with you you don't know when
it's coming but I mean here you are your
single guy great income living it up
basically is what it boils down to and
you're not alone there's plenty of
people doing that and they don't see
that this is a domino effect and it only
takes one Domino to fall for it all to
just you know roll down like that so
this is a Learning lesson not just for
you Daniel but there's plenty of people
listening who are right there and all it
takes is for their their
boss to say all right layoffs are coming
so we're all so many folks are learning
from you right now right now Daniel yeah
so what is your expenses to get by for
one month right now do you have uh rent
is it a mortgage
yeah it's a mortgage um I have a
mortgage and um right now um my monthly
expenses are about 10 519 goodness is
that because you have a giant mortgage
um I don't have I'm paying about thirty
three hundred dollars in my mortgage
yeah that I that's a lot of mortgage
right now for not having the income
well where's the other seven thousand
going this still feels like your
expenses are real high for a single guy
it's it's all the credit card debt yeah
okay these are all your minimum payments
it adds up 265 Grand have you started a
budget yet have you started I know you
said you've kind of started okay so you
you know exactly what you have you know
exactly what your margin could be
um
you're we're not just guessing is
basically what I'm getting no I'm I'm
telling you real numbers like I'm
reading from a cell spreadsheet all
right sweet that's good Daniel here's
the deal I'm scared for you and I'm
thinking through this if I was in your
shoes and if I didn't find a job like
the one I had before where I was making
six figures in the next few months I'm
going I need to look at selling this
house and then taking the net profit and
chunking it at the debt so what what
kind of equity do you have in the house
uh right now about 63
789 okay and plus you're 45 that would
knock out a good portion of your debt
over a third and and I've been told by
my realtor that you know she's thinking
um the area that I'm in that I could
make uh 75 to 100 000 profit from the
selling the home okay so even though you
have 63 in equity based on the sale
price you could make more even after
fees right so let's look at the career
side of it then with your job I mean how
quick let's be realistic if you really
you said you're hitting the pavement how
quickly could you find something where
you're making even if it's because let's
let's look at it on two sides you need
to get anything right now get any job
you know it's not may not be the dream
job but anything to float you until you
do get the dream job right
sorry okay so don't wait around for a
300 000 job yes go drive for Uber until
you make 150 and then jump to 250 when
you can yeah anything to stop the
bleeding because here's the thing if you
can get back to making 220 250 and you
can throw 130 000 at debt you're debt
free in two years so this is not a
hopeless scenario it just feels like
that right now because you got punched
in the face while you had a pile of debt
in front of you
right I also wanted to ask this question
too
um so I have a 401k and it has about
um I can withdraw about 302 thousand
dollars from it um should I leave that
alone uh because I could pay off my debt
right now with with you know the 401K
I'll leave it alone
okay in your 40s starting from scratch
it's there's too much growth potential
that will happen from that 300 000 for
you to liquidate that pay the penalties
pay the Inc it's just it's just triple
stupid so I would use your future income
you're not scared to work you're gonna
find that great job again you're going
to pay off this debt in a worst case
this house sale is Your Parachute to get
out of this thing and at least go rent
for a while and get out from under this
giant mortgage and get some roommates or
something major lesson learned man I'm
so sorry Daniel are you hoping you find
that next job soon
I appreciate it and yeah it's uh
definitely
one of the the low points of my life I
can tell you that for sure tough tough
tough stuff look Daniel's not all that
different we know a third of people who
make over 250 000 are living paycheck to
paycheck yeah and this is why you get
that big income and you're like oh I
like yourself do whatever I want you can
out earn your stupidity when you make
300 Grand and everyone thinks if I just
made that much man I would be no trouble
for me yeah right listen nobody's above
it we have to make these decisions every
day to stay out of debt to do the right
thing to have that money in the bank and
when you don't owe anyone anything a
layoff is a lot less scary but I'm glad
Daniel's at least got some cushion there
with 45k in the bank to float them by
until he can find that next gig but
scary situation right now this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see a chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined by Jade
warshaw this hour this is the Ramsay
show
well Jade I thought it would be fun to
play a little clip as we like to do when
it's you know it's a Friday we're
hanging out we're having a good time and
uh there's this guy out there named
Caleb Hammer have you heard of him love
that dude he's a he's a big YouTuber
he's got almost half a million uh
subscribers over there and he's become a
friend of ours yeah yeah he actually
followed the Ramsay principles he has
veered off we don't agree on everything
that's okay but when it comes to
budgeting and spending and not being
stupid with money we agree 100 love it
and so I wanted to play a video for you
and get your take on it and I think it
will spark an interesting discussion so
here we go with some Caleb Hammer
YouTube clips I just use the card for
the points
there is no points to be gained you're
losing to 11.50 what what
it's not worth me spending money and
everybody needs something if I'm not
getting the point
a month because you're not fully paid it
off why add to the balance ever because
this is how they get you and it works on
most people and worked on me so everyone
said it with me
it's okay that you're not do you know
what that means that I don't use them
correctly is that you you suck at them
they're getting money from you you're
not getting any benefit from them
oh my goodness he is wildly entertaining
wow he let her have it didn't he that's
his whole Channel they're called
Financial Audits and he'll just sit down
one on one and just yell at someone as
he goes through their Bank transactions
it sounds like a good time yeah we we
hope to do a little collab with him soon
for uh for our YouTubes and we'll have a
good time with that that is great I hope
he doesn't yell at me I'm nervous but
that really summed up an entire
generation's mentality when it comes to
credit cards I don't think anybody
should be a credit card person this idea
that like well yeah this is how no but I
like the I'm doing it for the points do
you understand America that getting one
percent cash back and paying 20 interest
means you're losing
that's first grade math yeah 20
negative bad one percent positive not
even close to good yeah and so here's
what people are saying when they say
well I'm gonna do the credit card game
I'm going to hope for the two percent
cash back which by the way just basic
math here Jade average household income
70 grand okay take-home pays 48. you
can't put everything on a credit card
you can't put your mortgage you can't
put your utilities facts so that brings
it down to about what twenty four
thousand in actual dollars you could put
on a credit card yeah
two percent of twenty four thousand
dollars
you're talking about 500 bucks a year if
you're lucky
biscuits so you can get access to the
AmEx Lounge once a year so you can get
500 airline miles which doesn't even
equate to 500 actual traveling miles so
you can get a one-way flight from
Nashville to Boise oh
it does not make it make sense Jade I
can't it I can't it's so ridiculous the
the amount that you would need to spend
for this to
I mean two percent everyone that opens a
credit card says well I'm gonna pay it
off every month it'll be fine I'll pay
it off like tomorrow I'll just take
advantage of the bonus the sign up offer
the rewards the miles and then I'll be
done and it doesn't work out that way
when I have those conversations I feel
Dumber afterwards because the the the
logic in the rhetoric is just so
mind-numbingly stupid and I'm like no no
no no no we get a lot of flack this is
probably our hottest most controversial
take here at Ramsey Solutions is that we
are very I cut up the credit card stick
to debit and we get so much Flack even
from our fans who I know we call them
Dave ish Jade because they're not all in
they're ish and they go I like the I
like the debt snowball but when I'm not
getting rid of my credit card because I
love XYZ yeah the credit card companies
are doing their job they're doing their
jobs marketing so well that you all out
there defend them you're defending these
billion dollar companies putting their
names on stadiums while they keep
America broke how do I know that because
credit card debt debt has hit one
trillion dollars at world record
congratulations trillion America has to
be number one at everything and uh we
did it Jade a trillion dollars in debt
oh and what what is our Parting Gift
George
uh for for winning this accomplishment
well billions of dollars in interest
paid America staying broke amidst
inflation uh uh under the guise of
winning with their credit card Awards so
here's uh here's the article from
payments.com I think that's how you
pronounce it yeah yeah uh and it says
last year was a different story when it
came to credit card debt as inflation
ate away at people's savings the Federal
Reserve increased interest rates against
this backdrop credit card debt surged by
a record 86 billion dollars in the
closing quarter of 2022 spending is
non-stop now we once thought of putting
things on our credit card as frivolous
spending like TVs and big purchases
now because of inflation people are
putting actual Necessities like food and
housing on their credit cards some
people some people are still going ham
on Lululemon has done better than ever
so we know people are yes there's some
folks struggling in that way but there's
a still a huge percentage of people who
have just said I liked my lifestyle
before and even though inflation it's
it's more expensive out there I don't
want to change my lifestyle so I'll just
use credit cards to float it well and
they go well I have no other option Jade
I was forced to because of inflation
without looking in the mirror and going
maybe you shouldn't have got that car
with a 600 a month payment okay maybe we
shouldn't have ignored student loans for
the last three years while we could have
actually made progress on them it's the
Comfort maybe we shouldn't have bought a
house because everyone said renting was
a sin and now we have a giant mortgage
payment and we can't afford to fix the
HVAC ah yeah and on top of all that
credit card companies are making record
profits because of these interest rates
the average credit card interest rate is
now almost 21 percent compared to 16
last spring wow and that I think
for like if you
've rates are almost 22 introductory APR
and you know what APR stands for added
pain and regret oh there it is that's
all it is that's scientific for your two
percent cash back
and this doesn't just affect people with
lower incomes who are struggling this is
the high income folks as well if you've
been listening to this show for the last
20 minutes you know that this you're
they're not immune to it just because
they make six figures especially as we
see more layoffs inflation people are
are struggling out there and it's one
more reason to avoid credit cards not to
join one to go this is the solution to
my problems I can still go on vacation
this year if I get enough points that's
an insane way to live and it's exactly
what the credit card companies want they
want you to be in the Maze chasing the
cheese yeah well they don't they they
want you to it's one of those things
where our brains would rather we would
rather do what we want to do right now
than think about how it could affect our
future yes that's just the way we're
wired we are very short-term in the
moment we don't want to think about that
and credit cards are like yes we will
take advantage of that and we will make
it to where you seemingly feel no pain
until the hammer drops hey hey you feel
that Caleb man you feel the pain you
know what I'm saying so I'm glad that
we're out there Caleb hammers out there
telling people the truth even when it
hurts even we have to yell at you
because we want you to win financially
and too many people out there are like
Jay don't tell me how to live my I'm
trying to live my truth out here your
truth is that you're broke and we want
to see you retire with dignity and break
generational curses yes so here's the
deal people tune into this show and they
know all the stuff we teach about money
and they still feel stressed out and
stuck why is that because knowing what
to do with your money is not the problem
we have all the information in today's
world we can Google it bro actually
doing it is the hard part and we know
that personal finance 80 Behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge and what got me
out of this cycle Jay because I was the
same person I was that girl going well
I'm gonna be the one to win until I
wasn't winning and I felt like a loser
because I was broke forty thousand
dollars in debt trying to play the Delta
SkyMiles game and the Discover game
getting my five percent rotating Cash
Back Rewards wow and so what got me out
of that was taking Financial Peace
University this is the class that is the
difference between trying to get in
shape on your own versus hiring a
personal trainer you'll have a
coordinator leading the class holding
you accountable with other people in the
class as well pushing you cheering you
on making you go oh I'm not the only one
that feels that way oh there's a path
out oh other people can do this that is
why this class has worked for millions
and after nine weeks doing this class
once a week you will never handle money
the same way again you're going to make
progress faster than ever so don't just
listen to the show don't just be Dave
ish don't just listen for entertainment
commit to doing what it takes to win
you can join an FPU class at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU and listen if this stuff doesn't
change your life you're just not trying
hard enough you didn't pay attention
enough you're not willing to do what it
takes and like Jade says don't tell us
that you can't do it you can tell us you
won't I know that's right you can do
this we've seen it happen we see it
happen every day George and I did it you
can too you're no different you are not
the exception to the rule you can change
your life change your money forever
break the cycle this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture of the day comes from
Philippians 1 6. he who began a good
work in you will perfect it until the
day of Christ Denzel Washington said
there is a lot of joy to be found in
reflecting upon your experiences as you
work toward your dreams learn to laugh
at your failures smile at your wins and
don't be afraid to laugh at yourself
okay I do a whole lot of that around
here that's for sure
can't take yourself too seriously that's
right well folks uh I don't know what
you're doing this Sunday but one thing
you could be doing is reading our Weekly
Newsletter that is completely free and
we've got 10 of the most common home
selling mistakes and how to avoid them
in uh this week's newsletter selling
your home is a huge deal one you don't
want to mess up and so you're not doomed
our team is going to walk you through
those mistakes and help you do this the
right way you can sign up for that
newsletter at ramseysolutions.com
newsletter and you will learn how to
sell your home the right way look that
news is on point it comes to my email
address here at work it's on point I
read it every every Sunday it's the
first thing I do when I wake up yep
there you go I love it all right
Christopher is up next in Cleveland
what's up Christopher
how are you good what's going on with
you
well I just have a quick question for
you guys uh I've been trying to follow
most of the baby steps and I believe
we're at the point of about paying off
our house and we're just wondering where
would be a good way to do it should we
take some money from this Roth IRA just
the original principal amount we have
some cash and some mutual funds in other
places but we really don't want to take
any kind of loss or penalty or should I
just keep paying
a bunch extra every month like I've been
doing I mean I've knocked down about 80
000 in the last you know two years
way to go so what's left on the mortgage
stuff to do
I have about 150 left okay and how much
money do you guys have in Savings in
cash
uh liquid Cash Cash let's say 50 between
the two of us between some mutual funds
and some other things probably 150
so these mutual funds are outside of
retirement
yes but you're saying you don't want to
liquidate those
I mean we could if you think that would
be a good route I mean I have another
mutual fund I mean a Roth IRA
is about 110 Grand well I've got about
150 in it 110 Grand of that I could take
with no penalty no early withdrawal fee
anything like that like that's the
original principle I put in I still I
still hate touching retirement accounts
it's not a this is not a spot where your
guys are on the verge of bankruptcy and
I understand that you can withdraw that
principle from the Roth IRA without
penalty but I just wouldn't do it I
think this is a it's a shortcut and it's
not going to feel as good when you pay
off the house knowing that you robbed
your retirement right in that sense
you're on you're still unplugging the
growth there
now the money if you have money just in
taxable brokerage that's invested in you
know whatever it's invested in whether
single stocks or you've got it in mutual
funds that you could access if you
wanted to but with 150 000 on your
mortgage hey what's your what's your
income
uh I should do the last couple years
it's been over 200. heckies I don't even
know if I would because your income's so
good and it's the other thing not
because I mean I've been going by your
Ramsey calculator I mean I have
roughly the pace I've been doing
probably about another a little less
than 30 payments I've been trying to add
about five grand every month to the
principal yeah great job what have you
been saving up in those mutual funds for
a long time ago at a different job I
mean I was a bricklayer and I didn't
have anything so it was just stuff I did
it's like an 18 20 year old kid and
coming to housing market back in OA
ended up having to go back to school and
change professions so I do something
completely different now what are the
tax implications if you cashed out all
of your non-retirement accounts what
would you owe in taxes
I don't know because I don't know how
that works I mean I guess I mean there's
been some Financial people we've dealt
with over the years I mean I'm sure I
could talk with them or be there I'm
sure a lot of it would be long-term
capital gains some of it if you've held
it you know less than a year could be
short term but I would talk to them and
see what the tax implications are
because if you could do that and pay off
the mortgage today it's what I would do
personally
okay I love the idea of you being debt
free today with no mortgage and making
200k you could save back up in a taxable
brokerage you could max out every
retirement account in the world without
a mortgage payment it's going to change
the game what's your mortgage payment I
mean
uh roughly right now like 22.60
awesome so you'll still have property
taxes and insurance to pay but you're
still going to free up probably what
1500 bucks a month
oh at least somewhere probably three to
five thousand I mean like I said I mean
it's been pretty good work the last few
years wouldn't that feel like at least
oh yeah I mean that's well you can Pat
your 18 and 20 year old self on the back
for doing all that work investing early
on to set you up for Success uh now that
you're older but man that's awesome way
to go Christopher what a great place to
be yeah I'm always in the boat of if
you've got money that's non-retirement
and you're just saving a save I'd rather
see you have that freedom that's true no
payment that's true but there's nothing
wrong if you want to just use your
future income to do it I mean he makes
200k he could throw 100K a year at that
thing and be done with it yeah I I think
either way would be fine I I think that
if it was I mean if the numbers were
slightly different let's say his
mortgage was a lot more and it was going
to take him many more years to pay it
off but he had the money I'd be like yes
let's go with him 150 he it's like right
on that line he's gonna get there yeah
he's gonna get there that's exciting
because he called in going I really want
to pay off this house I'm willing to
take it from my Roth to do it I'm going
I think you're right let's just do it
man all right wow cool stuff pretty cool
all right let's take one more from Jerry
in Madison Wisconsin and Jerry welcome
to the show
hi thank you for taking my call
um I'm trying to see if it's worth
buying my second rental uh property what
I have is
um a household income is about 80 000 a
year
and this house is worth uh seventy
thousand and I can come up with about
thirty five thousand dollars in cash so
I'd have to take a loan out for you know
roughly the other thirty five thousand
and I'm trying to find out if it if I
should do it or not so you have a
primary residence currently is that paid
for
yeah I have no debt at all of my current
house is worth probably 200 000 the
first rental house is probably worth
about seventy thousand awesome and that
one's paid for did you pay for that one
in cash or did you pay it off over time
uh paid then cash wow so what's stopping
you from paying this one in cash how
much longer would it take to do that
well the house is coming available here
real quickly and it's it's a property
that has kind of been in the family in
and out and I'd like to have it back
and it's so it's coming for it's coming
to uh up for sale and I have first dibs
on it but I just I don't have enough
cash and I don't want to take anything
out of any retirement or anything like
that yeah
um do you have non-retirement
invested money anything that's
non-retirement well that's what I'd be
using for the 35
000. got you
and how soon is this going to be up for
sale
uh probably about a week or two oh wow
and if you miss out you miss out is
someone in the family Gonna Take It
uh no someone in the family selling it
got it
so they're they're selling it uh from
what I'd get from the rent take away the
mortgage payment take away taxes
insurance and that I'd be making about a
hundred dollars a month on that house
but I'm confident with no debt we can
pay the mortgage payment you know with
my wife and I man I don't know if you're
gonna like my take but I would just wait
and do it cash and if you miss out
that's tough but making a hundred bucks
profit on this thing there's just way
too much risk even with this property
not being worth a whole lot all it takes
is one thing to go wrong to where you're
now underwater on this and that's my
worry it sounds sentimental right the
property because it's been in the family
can I ask you this right now I don't I
could buy the I could buy the house and
we could easily support this the
mortgage payment with my wife and I
because we have no debt we have you know
no money going out uh without dipping
into anything so we can cover it on our
income uh the mortgage itself how old
are you guys
uh 50 years old okay and you're still
working both of you
right so we're both working we can
easily cover that debt but you know we'd
actually be making money without
actually paying any of our money from
our job I'm here I'm hearing two things
one is this is sentimental family
property and others we're gonna make
money and it couldn't we can cover it
and I just don't think I would make the
decision based on either of those things
and so I would pass on it and I would
live with the regret of what could have
been the 100 bucks a month but I would
also sleep better at night without the
risk so thanks for the call man that
puts this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it
and want to know more about getting
started on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]